hello i'm jennifer aniston and I'm Reese
Witherspoon and we play news anchors on
the new morning show on Apple TV plus we
are so excited because we have a few
questions for a real morning show or
weaker guilty I'm ready okay Jennifer
Reese let's go cap here we go what time
does your alarm go off every morning 324
oh okay first thing you do when you wake
up how much TV that's the first thing I
do it's taking the news oh really
okay first maybe pee poppy or tea tea
definitely oh I hate coffee
okay I like the smell of coffee but I
hate the tapes yeah what kind of tea
Earl Grey with three creams three sugars
I love it and how many do you have her
before air just one yeah just well how
BIG's your mug it's the size of a
regular mud yeah it's good does my bit
muggier big or white hot chocolate - I
like that along with milk yes yeah so
that's okay so no I like white now have
a sugar crash I know I know
I know when I'm on a plane to fight at
10:00 don't say oh you like some tea
with your sugar I love sweets favorite
type of news to cover breaking oh I'm
breaking you know breaking news yes
terrific
do you ever unplug from the news Oh do
you ever unplug from the news cycle no
never
no okay I have a TV in every single room
in my house no no I love the news and
when you're not actually at the station
what do you how do you get your news
phone newspaper because you can get
everything online as you know get
everything Apple news is also very good
it's a good curator of news yes CBS n if
I wasn't doing so if Gail was not doing
morning news you would be doing you know
what I'd really like to do but I know I
can't don't say that I know I can't do
it why singing oh no to be on stage and
everybody I just did Bruce Springsteen
the other day yes so you're on stage and
everybody
those words to your song yeah Carrie
Underwood in your stand and people love
your music yeah I would do it really is
it's not an ego thing it's just that
music is so heat that's what I would
love to do also put my voice together it
does if you guys weren't doing what
you're doing what would you be doing
I've been a designer would you and Tara
what would you do designer or
dermatologist dermatologist brief I
wanted to be a pediatric cardiologist
when I was and don't worry it worked out
for ya what's the one thing people don't
know about putting together the morning
show it is harder than it looks
it is much people think you just sit up
there and read some words it's much
harder than it looks
and it takes an entire friggin village
to do it people don't understand that
because we're the faces so to speak but
as you know it takes a village to do it